she has been taking up a hobby i'm not
sure for how long of dancing with hula
hoops um you look carefully you might
even see some of those hula hoops so
everyone please welcome reena
they're your hula hoops everyone that's
awesome i want a big round of applause
arena take it away
thank you jared um okay so uh hi
everybody i'm rina and i'm going to be
talking today on a b testing of your
data science solution how we can prove
their uh actual value in real money or
whatever
it is that you're measuring in the
company clicks installs impression or
whatnot
um
yeah so i think you've all seen like
this picture or variant of it
how the front end looks versus to the
back end how the front end is all
beautiful with happy bunnies and
rainbows and the back end looks not as
nice
i think the very much applies for
actually experiments the front-end
experiment methodology is so firm is so
well designed and so well applied
while testing
back-end features which are
also includes data science models are is
not very much uh
it doesn't get much attention it's
deserved uh and i don't think it's a
very much uh it's not applied very well
i'm in a lot of places that i've seen
and very not well designed so i'm here
today to uh talk about uh how we can
test back-end uh features
so um just to be clear on what i'm
talking about when i'm saying front-end
basically front-end is everything that
the visual that is visual to the user it
may be color it may be text it may be
the structure of the website of the page
uh and then we have the split testing of
course that you i'm sure you're all uh
familiar with that uh we choose a
treatment group we
sample a percent of the traffic and then
we split them into two
uh some see version a and some are
exposed to version b and at the end we
compare clicks install or whatnot uh and
if we have a significance difference a
significant difference then uh we
succeeded in our experiment
uh so that's all good and nice for uh
anything that relates to the front end
uh but what about staff that don't
actually relate to front end and we are
not even not necessarily have front end
for example uh cue routing if we have a
system one of my uh clients they had a
system for uh cure routing they had a
chat bots it's not only bots also agents
uh and they wanted to redirect the
clients into uh into the queue
or have a smarter routing how do we test
that or uh for example uh item linking
and categorization if we want to change
the entire linking of items in our
website or design a new category tree
it's like too hard to split the traffic
and test it like you need to duplicate
the tree and whatnot it's not not even
cost beneficial
and then like other simple models even
like just a new clustering algorithm
that you apply that may affect some
feature that eventually affect a
recommendation
for the client uh how do you actually
isolate the value for that model
um yeah so this is like a sneak peek to
what we're going to be talking about
today
uh so the actual agenda is first why we
even want to experiment that's important
to understand the motivation i'm sure
you all do um
and then uh experiment design how we
actually want to do it and then
highlights and best practices of
experiments
okay so why
why we experiment i'm sure you all know
or been a part of a discussion of the
difference between causation and
correlation um so i'm going to do it
really brief but correlation
uh is the measure of how variables are
related to one another for example i
think the most famous example are sales
of sunglasses and cells of ice cream
they are both very correlated but
obviously they are affected from a third
factor
and sometimes variables may be
correlated and not necessarily a third
factor but a combination of other
factors and we don't even know what they
are
but we just know a trend um
and that's not good for us what we want
to do in terms of experiment we want a
causation a relationship we don't want
to understand the relationship between
cause and effect
um and guess what experiments are
basically the best way uh to to to have
this type of inference to infer for
inferring cause our relationships
um so that is basically the main reason
so if we want uh so we want to say that
money comes in because we did x because
our model we released the model and then
we know that as a result we increase the
profit of the company or we get more
clicks or whatnot we want to have that
type of relationship
okay
and then how uh the most interesting
part uh how we do that uh experimental
design
okay so um regular experiments as you've
all known uh they include uh hypotheses
right we have the alternative a and
alternative b and we want to compare
them and how and which one is better
uh we define our population usually uh
if it's front-end it's kind of its users
probably
a percent of the traffic
uh we have our matrices um
it can be a few of them but we
definitely want to have a main one and
then we have our time frame we have we
define the window of the test and we
have the before time frame and the after
and we compare everything here uh you
can see it uh
maybe a little bit better we choose a
percent of the traffic we do the split
and
i'm not talking right now about how we
split into groups but it's kind of like
a whole section later
um and then we split it into a treatment
and control group
and we track them both before the
release
basically both of them are in a very
same manner they see the exact same
version of the website or whatever it is
that i'm testing
and then we release our feature and
only to one group and the other group
remain untouched or a second version and
then we compare so we compare the
treatment group to before and after
and see the results and then the control
group before and after and see the
difference and then we compare these
differences and see if it was
significant and if we had an increase we
hope there was an increase in the
treatment group and a decrease in the
control group and then we can say yeah
the feature was successful
um
yeah but like we said before what
happened the percent of traffic it's not
always possible it's definitely not
possible in many cases and then what do
we do
examples um
so i mentioned it briefly before but
let's talk about it like items
re-categorization if i want to redesign
the category trainer in my website um
like it's not
it's really hard to test it if
like splitter traffic it's it doesn't
make sense right because then i would
need two category trees and then one
group goes to the older category tree
and the new and another group to the new
category and most of like most of the
sites i don't think they can afford that
um like duplicate their website and
we we can think about a better method to
do that so for example uh we can split
the categories
uh if we create two distinct groups of
categories and they have to be distinct
and i'm gonna attach that later but we
can imagine why right because uh we want
to isolate the impact and we don't want
uh people from one group uh go into
another group and then we won't be able
to understand uh uh if it was the model
that affected it or not we kind of want
it to be uh distinct
uh
when we choose the categories we want
them to be similarly distributed uh this
is something that we need to like
elaborate a little bit on uh
later or even now like what is the how
do we create two groups that are
similarly distributed um
i i actually have a slide on that but it
has to be like let's start with the
basic like about the same number of
categories they have to bring about same
and they have to hold about the same
amount of items or amount of visit
depends what i'm measuring and they
probably want to bring same amount of
like traffic or money or whatever it is
that i'm measuring so the distribution
has to be very similar so at the end i'm
able to compare the results so that
about categorization i can go i can also
approach it from the item level um not
necessarily for recategorization but if
i'm changing the items if i have the
models that let's say change the item
description
uh or something else or rerouting the
items or linking it
so i can create two distinct groups of
items
uh and then i'm actually converting the
entire test from the traffic to the back
end and again the group split here is
very very important it has to be two
similarly distributed group but it's
possible
uh another example is budget allocation
let's say that i'm a company that
manages manages a campaign social media
campaigns and i have a new algorithm for
budget allocation
so i want to understand uh how the new
algorithm affects
the campaign right i want to see more
money coming in more clicks um
so how do i do that uh usually people
tend to say slow release so let's say i
i release the model only on one campaign
and then five and then ten and then i
know 50
but i'm saying if you're already doing
like a slow release why not doing it
smartly like
sample from the beginning
like a few campaigns and compare them to
another group of campaigns that are
similar and then when you do the gradual
release you can you always have groups
that you can compare and actually know
that you have let's say you didn't make
any harm
to the to your uh budget allocator but
hopefully you had
uh you have increased some measures
um
so that's another way uh to split
entities that are different than users
um
for queue routing for example for this
company i was working with
they couldn't do that they couldn't
split the traffic at all and they
couldn't find any other solution because
when they apply the queue
it they have to apply it for all users
no matter what they cannot split
anything and they cannot split it
gradually and
it was a problem and i'll tell you in a
second how we solved it
um but basically my suggestion is uh you
split other entities you don't
necessarily split the users you choose
another entity
um
hopefully the one that that your model
actually calculated for example if
you're trying to optimize campaigns or
campaigns if you're redirecting items
then items and so on
and then you use the very same
methodology here which is very
well designed and also well like it's
well known and very easy to digest
and uh easy to prove also that uh that
we can uh
lease that money that came into the
model so i'm all i'm suggesting
suggesting here is to change the entity
at the beginning of the test or the
experiment
um
so like i said before so in the
categorization we can have it on backend
and also the budget allocator the cure
outing we couldn't
because we have to release it all at
once so but even in like these extreme
cases that we cannot find any other
solution there are i call it creative
split
uh when we split uh the days of the week
so for example they had to do to release
the entire queue so we had kind of a
slow release
um we took the tr the treatment group to
we took two weeks time frame
and
the even days at the first week and the
odd days at the second week or the
treatment group so we kind of turned the
feature back on and off
each and every day and at the end of
these two weeks we had one week as a
treatment group and then a second week
of uh a control group uh we could have
done it week after week but it was too
jumpy when we looked at the data before
like the data i had significant changes
from week to week so we decided to go
uh like a day on and off
um and it was actually really uh nice to
see the value from that type of
experiment
um
yeah so so we said about like entity
selection so definitely define the test
population it can be items it can be
campaign it can be the pages on your
website it can be anything but it has to
be like a very well-defined unit
the group split
which i'm going to be talking about in
the next slide and then we have the
creative split
which is kind of a slow release but it's
a smart slow release
um
yeah and then going directly to the
highlights um so
i'm okay sampling methodologies it's
kind of a whole topic and i think we can
designate at least one like
definitely we can fill in one talk just
about sampling methodology or even a
whole semester
uh but i'm just gonna give the
highlights here um i'm going to start
with random versus stratified sampling
so for example if i'm working at ebay
and um i'm going to be randomly sampling
the website the items on the website i'm
going to be having like i know 50 books
because they have a lot of books items
but no one cares about them because they
care about electronics electronics sells
the best so what i would want to do
there it's kind of a stratified sampling
right take each catalog and sample let's
say 100 items or 1000 items from each
catalog and then that will create a
stratified sample
um
and then here i want to talk about the
practice of randomization uh ensuring
groups equivalent
in composition so how do we do that so
let's say i'm creating these two groups
of items
and i want to consider the target kpis
as clicked
so i'm taking these two groups of items
and i'm measuring the clicks in each
group and i i'm sorry we start with one
group and i'm looking at all the clicks
and then i sample it by the clicks
or i can sample it by clicks and
impression or i can have it like
two-dimensional three-dimensional or
whatnot so the groups are
the distribution is very much similar in
each one of this feature that i just
selected
uh so that's a way to split the groups
in kind of a similarly distributed
manner
um
another thing to sample like i said
before it's days of the week we can
sample like even on odd days uh
sometimes we do week after week uh so
that's another type of sampling as well
and then i kind of the million dollar
question that i'm always getting it's
like the sample size uh so i just want
to say there are sampling calculators
that if you define your mod the margin
of error and confidence level so you can
pretty easily
calculate what's the best sample size uh
i added here like a cheat sheet if you
guys remember like i know
like uh
statistical classes uh we can calculate
the sample size basically pretty easily
so you can calculate the sample size for
every margin of error and confidence
level you choose
um
and then other important consideration
it's actually kind of funny how um
conflicts like very
basic stupid conflicts in the company
may uh hurt the experiment for example
if i release something and i did like a
kind of a back-end experiment and then
another guy from a different department
had another release at the very same
date
uh now if i had my groups pl my group
splitted correctly it shouldn't affect
that much but still i want to keep a
clean environment
so um
you can like control it with kind of
product announcement or like just you
know have like a calendar in your
company about experiment that's kind of
the right way to go but definitely
communicate with with other people in
your company to understand that you're
not both experimenting at the very same
time another thing that i saw that is
very very uh interesting that you have
to really define the kpi formula
um it's very different when you measure
it on user and then when you measure it
on item right it's kind of it's a little
bit different and then what's the right
formula and then you can have it
significant in one formula and then not
insignificant and then insignificant in
another way you calculate it so you
definitely want to define it before you
take the um
before you start the experiment
um other effects that may happen it's
kind of a network effect that's mainly
in social media and this is something we
have to analyze in advance see how users
interact with one another in the uh on
our platform uh if that happens we
definitely want to take that into
consideration maybe analyze the sender
and receiver separately or unders or
again create distinct groups this is
like an issue that we need to uh
understand how uh to work with and then
cannibalism of fact that of campaigns
for example if i do let's say i do two
groups of campaigns
there may be the
the good group that the one that has my
models on uh kind of attract all the
traffic from other campaigns and then
that's not really fair game right
uh so i need to think what to do there
as well uh we need to consider
everything and analyze our data
before um
that's it i hope i uh convinced you of
like at least exploring some ways to
test in your data science models and
improve your their values um thank you
thank you very much
thank you reena that was terrific a b
testing is
a very popular topic i know that at the
meetup and at the conference we've had
multiple a b testing talks because it's
so important if you go to
rstats.ai there's actually a video tab
and you can see all the past years
videos that's six years of nyr and three
years of our gov
you